es el segundo país más poblado de la
tierra la séptima mayor economía uno de
los diez estados con mayor presupuesto
militar y uno de los pocos con armas
nucleares a pesar de ello la india es en
términos políticos que un país
prácticamente desconocido
en un anterior con seca os preguntaba
por el nombre del presidente de china
pues bien yo en este vídeo pues hago una
pregunta similar cuál es el nombre del
primer ministro de la india sé que
muchos lo sabréis si no es así no os
preocupéis tampoco es extraño
el 26 de mayo de 2014 tras obtener una
mayoría absoluta inédita en 30 años
narendra modi se convirtió en el primer
ministro de la india su misión era clara
impulsar el crecimiento la inversión y
crear millones de empleos
en definitiva convertir a la india en
una superpotencia capaz de competir con
china a nivel económico militar y
política no sólo por agua porque la
india es amigos de visual política algo
así como la eterna promesa el país que
siempre parece que va a despegar pero
que al final se queda en tierra de hecho
basta con fijarse en cómo han
evolucionado los pib de china y la india
en las últimas décadas
pues bien con la victoria de modi las
expectativas se volvieron a disparar y
hoy la india vuelve a estar de moda el
propio móvil no se cansa de repetir que
el siglo 21 será el siglo de la india
pero antes que nada
vegetariano soltero y practicante de
yoga no hubiese un político que escapa
al perfil convencional procede de una
familia humilde y de niño ayudaba a su
padre a venderte en una estación de tren
esto es algo que le ha hecho ganarse la
simpatía de muchas personas pobres del
país que ven en él una muestra de que el
ascensor social a veces funciona
[Aplausos]
su pensamiento político siempre ha
estado muy ligado al hinduismo aunque no
siempre bajo planteamientos moderados de
hecho antes de militar en el viejo tape
lo hizo en el rss un partido de extrema
derecha del que formó también parte
nathuram godse el asesino de mahatma
gandhi bien durante 13 años entre 2001 y
moody fue el primer ministro regional
del estado de gujarat que con 65
millones de habitantes se convirtió bajo
su dirección en la locomotora de la
india logrando un crecimiento anual
medio durante su mandato de más del 10
por ciento anual y claro junto a ello
también mejoraron todos los parámetros
de bienestar social prácticamente todos
los hogares lograron acceder a servicios
de agua electricidad y educación
infantil precisamente durante la campaña
de las elecciones generales modi
prometió replicar en la envía el éxito
de gujarat y prometió hacerlo además en
apenas 10 años en dos mandatos
porque para moody 2022 es el año clave
se celebrará el 75 aniversario de la
independencia de la india el país
superará china como el más poblado con
más de 1600 millones de habitantes y
según móvil quedará claro que este es el
siglo de la india pero no será fácil la
india un país cuya población crece ojo
al ritmo de 28 habitantes cada minuto es
compleja
los grandes problemas de la y
son muchos los problemas de este país
pero podemos destacar tres primero su
enorme burocracia la india amigos es el
paraíso de la burocracia de hecho si
éste fuese la clave de la prosperidad la
india probablemente sería el país más
rico del mundo desgraciadamente la
burocracia en vez de alentar los
negocios acaba con ellos john kerry el
secretario de estado de la
administración obama alerta en su última
visita a la india que la burocracia pone
en riesgo el crecimiento del país según
el informe doing business del banco
mundial que mide la facilidad para hacer
negocios la india ocupa el puesto 130 en
este país cada trámite requiere de
montones de papeles y los impuestos
además de ser altos aunque pocos los
pagan hay que decirlo son un infierno
por ejemplo no es que existan muchos
impuestos diferentes en cada estado no
es que muchas veces los impuestos son
diferentes para cada producto y en
algunos casos para cada modelo de un
mismo producto como ocurre con los
automóviles una locura
y además el absentismo entre los
funcionarios es tan alto que se han
reportado casos de hospitales cerrados
porque los funcionarios no iban a
trabajar aquí al menos llegan tarde este
funcionario
y cuál es su boba dios la vocal cuál es
su boca te trae pues mi horario de
entrada me abstengo de decirlo ahora que
son las nueve menos cuarto bueno yo
estoy me dormido el segundo como
consecuencia de las complejas
regulaciones la ruptura del mercado es
casi total en los pasos fronterizos
entre los diferentes estados que
componen el país los caminos de
mercancías se acumulan en colas
interminables y no son pocos los que
dicen que es más fácil importar que
comprar en el interior del país tampoco
ayuda el estado ruinoso de las
infraestructuras públicas pues bien se
calcula que la mitad de las cosechas se
pierden antes siquiera de llegar a los
mercados tercero la corrupción es una
lacra muy extendida por toda la sociedad
por ejemplo el 50 por ciento de todas
las ayudas entregadas por el gobierno a
familias y personas pobres se quedan en
manos de intermediarios y políticos
corruptos este es el país al que se está
enfrentando móvil
y políticas del nuevo gobierno
aunque no haya llevado a cabo la
revolución que algunos planteaban la
verdad es que el nuevo gobierno ha
realizado en poco tiempo avances muy
destacados entre las apuestas del
gobierno indio podemos destacar las
siguientes para reducir la burocracia el
gobierno ha formado una comisión que
tiene como meta determinar qué leyes y
normativas están obsoletas y deben ser
eliminadas y llevan más de 1700 moody ha
suprimido muchas restricciones a la
inversión extranjera ha aprobado la
primera ley de quiebras y ha puesto en
marcha un potente programa para
promocionar a la india como destino para
empresas indias reconocido en una clara
oportunidad de inversión ahora de
empresas extranjeras casi un 60 por
ciento del producto interior bruto indio
procede de consumo interno se ha
impulsado también un programa muy
ambicioso para lograr una mayor
inclusión financiera el programa que
tiene este nombre que veis
impronunciable ya ha logrado que más de
200 millones de personas tengan por
primera vez una cuenta bancaria de esta
forma por ejemplo las subvenciones ya no
pasarán por intermediarios el gobierno
está liderando la implantación de un
impuesto único sobre las
a nivel nacional que tiene que terminar
con el caos del actual sistema
impositivo móvil ha anunciado una
importante inversión en infraestructura
tan solo en la red ferroviaria 130 mil
millones de dólares hasta 2020 el
gobierno indio quiere atraer a más
inversores estadounidenses entre otras
cosas para modernizar la deteriorada
infraestructura sin buenas carreteras y
puertos la economía india no avanza con
todo su medida más polémica y más
arriesgada llegó en noviembre de 2016
[Música]
crisis de efectivo de la rubia para
luchar contra la corrupción y el vino
negro el gobierno ilegal hizo a
principios de noviembre de 2016 los
billetes de 500 y mil rupias que
representaban atentos más del 85% del
efectivo de un país en el que casi todos
los pagos se hacen con casi la medida
tenía como objetivo lograr cazar el
dinero negro y paralizar lo cuando sus
dueños fuesen a cambiarlo por los nuevos
billetes pues bien el plan ha sido un
total desastre el gobierno no tenía
suficientes billetes nuevos para
sustituir los viejos y los cajeros ni
siquiera estaban adaptados porque los
nuevos billetes tienen tamaños distintos
una chapuza que ha dejado al país sin
dinero ocasionándole un gran daño a la
actividad económica que están haciendo
estamos angustiados hoy no comimos nada
espero conseguir pronto dinero
las ventas se hundieron en noviembre más
de un 30% muchos centros de trabajo no
han podido pagar a sus trabajadores y
muchísimas operaciones se han cancelado
algunos estudios cifran el daño en al
menos dos puntos del pib
es decir al país le puede costar esta
chapuza casi 50 mil millones de dólares
por supuesto los más perjudicados una
vez más han sido los más pobres
agenda exterior este es el campo donde
más ha destacado el nuevo primer
ministro indio tan solo en su primer año
visitó 19 países
[Música]
y a pesar del poco tiempo transcurrido
ya ha conseguido avances el trato con
pakistán ha registrado síntomas de
mejora en la relación con china parece
que comienza a canalizarse hacia la
vertiente económica y comercial de kim
se compromete a invertir en la india 100
mil millones de dólares en los próximos
años aunque sin duda alguna el punto
fuerte de la agenda ha sido su
acercamiento a los eeuu de hecho ha sido
muy significativa la buena conexión
entre obama y móvil sus encuentros han
sido frecuentes y muy amistosos ambos
escribieron por cierto un artículo
conjunto en el washington post que fue
toda una declaración de intenciones la
pregunta ahora es conseguir a modi sus
objetivos a priori parece difícil porque
si algo está demostrado es que es muy
complicado limitar la burocracia allí
donde ha cobrado mucho peso y aquí la
india se lleva la palma por otro lado
moody ha guardado en el cajón muchas
reformas imprescindibles como por
ejemplo poner fin a una regulación
laboral que ocasiona que cuatro quintas
partes de los trabajos sean informales
modi afirma ser un admirador de lee kuan
yew pero no está claro que tenga la
misma determinación para transformar
el ruinoso modelo de la india espero que
te haya gustado este vídeo si ha sido
así
no olvides suscribirte avisa al político
pinchando en este botón y los próximos
domingos podrás también encontrarnos en
la vanguardia
por cierto queremos dar las gracias a
alejandro esteban por la ayuda que nos
ha prestado para hacer este vídeo y os
recomendamos seguir su canal el arte de
invertir en youtube un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]